i'm assuming you're alfred
am i crazy or did we finally get to see
superman in
the black suit we are gonna break all of
this down for you and tell you what this
means for
zack snyder's version of justice league
right now on the ketchup during justice
con which was happening at the same time
but you know just
down the virtual street from comic-con
at home a panel
centered around zack snyder revealed
some pretty interesting details about
his version of justice league which is
coming to hbo max
next year counting down the days and he
debuted a never-before-seen clip that
features henry cavill superman wearing
the black suit while meeting alfred
played by of course jeremy irons
a lot of star power in one scene well
that was fun while it didn't
last now basically the black suit dates
back to the comics in the 90s when a
pretty huge deal was made about the
death of superman at the hands of
doomsday which is also who killed him in
batman v superman dawn of justice
but when he inevitably returned in the
comics he initially wore a black version
of his iconic suit which has since
become a popular piece of superman lore
also most of us just look better in
black anyway right so it was thought
that when superman was resurrected in
justice league we would see it which
snyder has said was his intention from
the beginning so in other words it looks
like we'll be getting more of superman's
resurrection story
of course his original version was
drastically changed by new director joss
whedon
after snyder left the project and for
more on that check out our past episodes
about the snyder cut
meaning we did not see the black suit in
the version that exists right now which
is a rotten 40
on the tomato meter by the way right
ain't over yet amen
the closest we have come to seeing it
was actually in a deleted scene that
came with the justice league blu-ray
release remember those
and in it we see clark kent in the
fortress of solitude walking past both
the black suit and some kryptonian space
armor
can we talk about how dope that closet
was though funny enough that scene could
have really helped superman's character
arc in justice league which is one of
the many reasons fans have demanded to
see
a snyder cut good so i really like being
alive
speaking of which schneider also teased
on the panel that he is trying to secure
the name
zack snyder's justice league for the
film but isn't sure if that's legally
possible
would love your thoughts on that one and
the clip that was shown
shows off one of his main focuses which
is restoring the film's intended aspect
ratio adding that a lot of important
parts of scenes were actually cropped
out of the frame
with that snyder was sure to be clear
that he most definitely won't be using
any footage that wasn't shot by him so
in other words goodbye to superman cgi
upper lip
rip i know you
all right friends it's time for us to
kick it over to you now what are you
most excited to see in zack snyder's
version of the justice league please
unload all your thoughts and feelings in
the comments section
and if you want more movie and streaming
news head on over to rottentomatoes.com
but
all of it doesn't stop there guys join
us on our fan group on facebook because
we can chat about the black suit the
blue suit i mean
heck even the non-existent purple suit
whatever we want and connect
there and if you don't want to miss out
on any future episodes of this show be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup so
thank you and we hope to see you in the
next video bye
[Music]
you